[音楽]
[拍手]
皆さんはじめましてこんにちは
先ほどご紹介に預かりました私
川崎雄一郎と申します本日私がお話したい
テーマ
辛いこと日記を残そうこのテーマですね
あーつらかったなーっていうこの過去の
経験そこにこそですね自分らしさが実は
眠ってるんではないかそして今あなたが仮
に苦しいこと
葛藤していることこういうことを乗り越え
たいそういった時の
勇気や希望どうやったら振り絞ればいいの
かそういった気づきのお話となっており
ます
まずですけれども
突然ですが皆さんたんぽぽの姿を
思い浮かべてくださいと言われたらどう
いった姿を思い浮かべますか
おそらく大体の方が
黄色い姿を思い浮かべるんじゃないですか
ねいや私は
綿帽子を飛ばす白い姿を思い浮かべたよ
そういった方もいらっしゃるかもしれない
ですところがですよ
タンポポのあの黄色い花って1年間のうち
たった1週間だけの姿なんですね
ではその1週間が過ぎた後一体どういう姿
になってるかというと
夏から先は実は
根っこだけの姿になってるんです
そして
夏を過ぎて
秋を超えて
冬を越えてそしてまた春になったそうし
たらあの花をたった7日間だけまだ咲かせ
た後は
夏から先はまた根っこだけの姿になるん
ですね
たんぽぽの姿ってたんぽぽの生姜って
ずっとこれの繰り返しなんです
私はこのタンポポのですねこの生涯を
見つめてあなるほどねって思ったことが
あるんですそれは一体何なのかと
タンポポがですねその生きる一番の目的
って実はあの黄色い花を咲かせることそれ
自体にあるのではなくて彼らが一番時間を
かけていることって何なんだろうとそれは
地中深くに
根を伸ばし続けることなのではなかろうか
とそして目を伸ばし続けた結果あの黄色い
花が咲いたのではなかろうかと私はそこ
から感じ取ったんですねこの
タンポポの障害って
我々人間の生涯にもすごく似たようなこと
がいるんじゃないかなって思ってるんです
例えばですねどういうことかというと本日
ちょっと暗いな本日は皆様ですねまあ
ちょっと暗いんですよ私のその想像力では
すごく皆様整った顔をされた皆様だと思う
んですねなんですけれどもこの今の皆様の
この美しく形成された姿というのはこれを
形成する一番大きな要素って何なん
でしょうかね
先ほどのたんぽぽの話を思い出しますね
そうこの
我々を掲載している一番大きな要素って
この根っこの部分なんですけれどもでは
この
根っこの部分を人間の人生に控えたら何に
例えられるんでしょうか
それは私たち一人一人が人知れず続いてき
た
奇跡にあるんだと思うんですそしてここの
奇跡にこそその人それぞれの感じ方とか
考え方とかそういったその人らしさがここ
にあるんだろうなと私はタンポポの生涯を
通じてそう感じたんですね
私がこういった感じ方
これをこういう風に感じるようなきっ
かけっていうのが
辛いこと意識を残すというこの習慣から
始まってるものなんですけれどもまずです
ねこの辛いこと日記を始めるにあたった
きっかけなんですけれども私ですね実に
その地元にですねすごい仲の良い友人がい
てその方が文房具マニアのニートの方だっ
たんですこの方がですね私の誕生日に1冊
の手帳を
プレゼントしてくださいましたその時です
ね私ですねこの手帳の1冊の使い方をです
ねその将来の計画であったりとかあるいは
日々の活動の記録であったりとかそういっ
たオーソドックスな使い方をしてたんです
けれどもこれがですねだんだんだんだんと
自分のですねその気持ちとか内面とかと
いった感情の記録になっていったんですね
で例えばそのいつの日からかそのね
苦しかったなぁとかあるいはちょっと凹ん
だなってなった時にその記録をですね
パラパラパラパラめくるようになってたん
ですねするとそこには
たった今苦しんでいる
凹んでいるようなその自分と全く同じ姿の
過去の自分がそこの記録の中にはその対峙
してたんですね
例えばなんですけれども私ですね過去に
こういったことがあったんですねこの中で
も特に象徴的なエピソードとしては私です
ね社会人になってからではあるんです
けれども一度公認会計試験のこの国家資格
を目指してた時期がございましたこの当時
ですね私ホテルのフロントの仕事をして
おりましてなのでこのホテルの仕事とあと
公認会計試験の仕事ですね仕事や勉強です
ねこれをその
並行する生活っていうのを3年半ぐらい
続けた時あったんですねで3年半続けた
結果試験
合格しましたおめでとうございます」って
いう話だったらまあよかったんですけれど
も
これがですね現実はそうはうまくいかなく
て
見事に敗れてしまって
挫折してしまったとそういった経験が
ございました
この時の私の心境なんですけれどもこの3
年半かけて頑張ったっていうこの時間の
重みよりかは
もうこれ以上頑張れないっていうそういう
自分の限界に気がつかされたことここが
すごく辛くてですねもうそこから先はもう
夢とか目標とかも持つのはやめようともう
そこにはもう目を向けないようにしようと
そういった日々が何年も続きました
そして何年も続いてだいたい5年以上過ぎ
たぐらいですかね私ですね結構本を読むの
が好きでしてとある時ですねまあ近くの
大きめな本屋に寄ったんですよで本屋に
行くとですねよく何か資格者のなんか棚
みたいなとかあるじゃないですかであの棚
ですねちょっと私はそういった記憶がある
のでなるだけ目にしないようにもう
通り過ぎちゃってたんですねなんだけど
たまたまですねちょっと目にしちゃってで
その時にその資格の棚上げですね別の資格
そう中小企業診断士っていうですね別の
国家資格の
過去問がですねその棚に平積みされていた
んですね
で私はですねなんだかその
素通りできない気持ちがあったのか
たまたまその中の一冊をパって手に取って
でそれをパラパラパラパラ開いてみたん
ですよ
そしたらですね私ですね
親と
あれこの問題今の自分でも解けるんじゃ
ないのと
もしかしたらこの試験だったら
頑張れば通過できるんじゃなかろう
かそう思ったんですけれどもその矢先です
よまた別の考えが頭の中よぎってくるわけ
ですね
ここで
挑戦するなんて決めてしまったらまた仕事
と勉強を並行する生活を何年も送らなけれ
ばいけなくなってしまうそしてまた失敗
するに違いない
私はですねここで今
挑戦するべきかせぬべきかものすごく
悩んだんですカットしたんですそして
葛藤したその時の私が一体何をしたのかと
言いますと
友人からそのいただいたその手帳ですね
パラパラめくってたんですそうこれが辛い
こと日記なんですけれども確かにそこには
ですねあの時勉強と仕事を並行する生活は
どれだけ大変だったのかそして試験に敗れ
てどれだけ悔しかったのかそういった
気持ちがすごく赤裸々に書かれていたん
ですただですよ書かれていたのはそれだけ
ではなかった
希望になる一言も書かれていたんですね
それが私は結果は出せなかったけれども
精一杯努力できることには気がついた
そう私はですね
敗れ去ったあの時からずっと
結果は出せなかったその事実にばかり目を
向けていたんだけれどもただよく考えてみ
たら3年半仕事と勉強並行してあれだけ
頑張ったじゃないかと
私はその事実には全然目を向けてこなかっ
たんですね
そして私は3年半
頑張ったんだっていうこの自分の姿を
信じて
よしもう1回だけ挑戦してみようじゃない
かと
そういう気持ちになって一歩前に進むこと
ができたんです
私はこの経験を通じて皆様にですねお伝え
したいアイデアが辛いこと日記を残そうっ
ていうアイデアなんですけれどもこれが
ですね特に大切なことというのがまず今
あなたが葛藤してる事実そしてその
葛藤に対して感じていることそしてあなた
はこの方を一体どうしたいのかこれを
素直に記録してでこの記録をですね
将来のあなたが振り返った時にどのように
心が
揺り動かされるのか
ここがものすごく重要なところなんです
そしてですよ
この
辛いこと日記を残そう
振り返ろう
ここにはものすごく大きな一つの目的が
ございますそれが
点と点をつなぐための
軌跡をつける上での点を描くことなんです
この点を描くってどういうことだろうって
ことなんですけれども私はこのように考え
ております
瞬間に
火花のように生まれてくる競技や活動そこ
に対して全勢力を持って力を入れることで
あると
ちょっと大げさな言い方しちゃったんです
けれども
妻やこういうことです
今あなたがやりたいと思ってることがある
のだとしたらそこのに対して正直な気持ち
で
挑戦してみればいいじゃないかと
ところがですよ
我々って
挑戦すること
点を描こうとすることしばしば
諦めちゃうことってありませんかね
例えばですね私たちがちっちゃかった頃
幼かった頃って本当になんか思った通りの
ことになんか手足動いてたじゃないですか
なんだけど
我々
成長するに従っていって
他人の顔色を伺ったりだとか
損得感情で物事を考えたりだとか
結果を求めてしまうからこそ動けなくなっ
てしまうことだったりとかそういうことっ
て私にはですねやっぱり思い当たること
ありますしもしかしたら皆さんにも
思い当たることがあるかもしれない
ただ
点を描くことこれって
成長するにしたがって
失われていく能力なんでしょうか
いや
むしろですよ
点を描くことって
能力があるからこそできることなん
でしょうか
ここに対して私はこう考えています
点を描くことは一番重要なのは能力その
ものではない
過去にあなたが抱いた
情熱
希望
勇気を取り戻すことである
ところがですねもう一つここでちょっと
問題があるんですけれども
例えば
勇気や情熱希望を抱いたような心を
揺さぶられるような出来事って人間ここの
記憶にはなかなか記憶には残そうとするん
だけれども
記録にはなかなか残そうとしないんですよ
ね
人間の記憶ってなんか月日が過ぎたらなん
か薄まってっちゃうじゃないですか
いや
むしろですよ例えば
辛かったこと
葛藤したことっていうそういった記憶って
皆さんどんどん忘れちゃおうとしてません
かね
確かにもう辛いこと日記を残すとか
振り返るとか
このアクションそのものが自傷行為のよう
に辛いことかもしれないです
ただ私はですねこの辛いことに気を
振り返っていつも気がつかされることが
あるんですね
それが一体何なのかっていうと自分
らしさってこういうことだったんかって
いうことです
自分らしさって自分の価値観で自分で考え
て自分で決めてそして自分で行動を取る
この行動の結果ですね前向きに物事が進む
こともあるかもしれないけれども一方で逆
にですね
新しいハードルが生まれてしまった新しい
苦しみが生まれてしまった
そういった痛みを伴うものかもしれない
ただそういった痛みや苦しみをすべて
ひっくるめてこその自分らしさじゃないの
かなっていうことです
私はこの気づきを通じて
一歩そう点を描く大きな勇気や情熱を
沸き起こすことができました
私は4年前に地元を離れて東京に出てきて
やりたい仕事について大学
院に通ってそして今こうやって皆様の前に
立たせていただいております
最後に今回のトーク
辛いこと日記を残そうのまとめでござい
ますこの
辛いこと日記を残そうというアイデアです
けれども
今あなたが抱えてるこの葛藤そしてそれに
対しての思いこれを記録してこの記録を
ですね
将来のあなたが
振り返った時にどういう風にその感情が
揺さぶられるのか
将来のあなたが点を描こうともがこうとし
ていたのであればその時にどういう風に
勇気を持って前に進むことができるのか
そのためのアイデアでございます
私たち誰しもがですよ
過去の葛藤の上に今の自分が
成り立っております
きっと
小さかった頃に地中に貼った自分の根っこ
は今もまだ皆様の中に残ってるはずです私
の本日のトークはここで終了でございます
皆様ご清聴本日はどうもありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]